pour lutter contre le froid cécile iban
une vague de grippe déferle sur la
france pour lutter efficacement contre
ce mal nous vous conseillons de prendre
les médicaments de votre choix
accompagné d'une boisson chaude et pour
changer nous vous recommandons le vin
chaud aux cerises 450 g de cerises dit
griotte au sirop et surtout non
dénoyautées que vous trouverez
facilement dans le commerce tous les
épiciers et dont vous ne jetterai pas le
ciron car ce sirop pour à sucre est une
complète ses cerises seront égoutter
puis écrasez à la fourchette
[Musique]
moi
quelques noyaux seront concassés en
effet le noyau de cerise complète et
confirme le goût des fruits
une bouteille de vin d'alsace sera versé
dans une casserole un vin blanc sec peut
également faire la ferme et le vin
d'alsace accommode parfaitement avec le
parfum des cerises dans ce bas vous
mettrez les cerises et les noyaux
prépare
et vous ajouterez 20 morceaux de sucre
vous mélangerez bien doucement
[Musique]
vous couvrirez et vous maintiendrez en
ébullition 30 minutes
[Musique]
avant de servir vous filtrez votre
boisson choisissez de préférence des
verts et impôts qui supporte la chaleur
car ce vin aux cerises doit être servi
très chaud et après mais après si vous
avez encore la grippe recommencer
[Musique]
mais